De ese modo descubrimos
que necesitamos cambiar el enfoque mundial de la escolarización al aprendizaje,
de solo contar cuántos cuerpos hay en las aulas
a contar cuántos están aprendiendo.
Y la segunda gran tarea fue,
¿podemos hacer algo al respecto?
¿Podemos hacer algo con esta gran crisis mundial tan vasta y silenciosa,
y quizá en gran parte desatendida?
Y descubrimos que sí, podemos hacer algo.
En realidad es increíble.
Por primera vez podemos
tener a todos los niños en la escuela aprendiendo
en solo una generación.
Y no tenemos que reinventar la rueda para lograrlo.
Solo tenemos que aprender de los mejores en su clase,
pero no el mejor de cualquier clase,
el mejor en tu propia clase.
Analizamos los países por nivel de ingresos:
bajos ingresos, ingresos medios, altos ingresos.
Observamos el 25 % de los factores que más aceleran la mejora educativa,
y descubrimos que
si cada país se mueve al ritmo de los factores más dinámicos
dentro de su propio nivel de ingresos,
entonces dentro de una sola generación
podemos tener a todos los niños en la escuela aprendiendo.
Les daré un ejemplo.
Tomemos a Túnez, por ejemplo.
No le estamos diciendo a Túnez: "Debes moverte tan rápido como Finlandia".
Sin ánimo de ofender, Finlandia.
Le estamos diciendo a Túnez,
"Mira a Vietnam".
Gasta cantidades similares para alumnos de primaria y secundaria
respecto al porcentaje del PIB per cápita,
pero logra resultados más altos.
Vietnam introdujo una evaluación de alfabetización y aritmética,
se controla mejor a los docentes que en otros países en desarrollo,
y los logros de los estudiantes se hacen públicos.
Y eso se ve en los resultados.
En el informe PISA 2015
-- Programa de Evaluación Internacional de Estudiantes --
Vietnam superó a muchas economías ricas,
incluyendo a Estados Unidos.
Ahora, si uno no es un experto en educación,
podría preguntarse: "¿Qué hay de nuevo y diferente?
¿No registran todos los países el progreso de los estudiantes y publican sus logros?"
No. La triste respuesta es que no.
Estamos muy lejos de eso.
Solo la mitad de los países en desarrollo
hacen evaluación sistemática del aprendizaje en primaria,
y aún menos en los primeros años de la escuela secundaria.
Entonces, si no sabemos
si los niños aprenden,
¿cómo harán los maestros para centrar su atención en conseguir resultados,
y cómo se supone que los países priorizarán el gasto en educación
para conseguir resultados,
si no saben si los niños aprenden?
Por eso la primera gran transformación
antes de invertir
es hacer que el sistema educativo entregue resultados.
Porque poner más dinero en sistemas rotos
solo financiará más ineficiencias.
Y lo que me preocupa profundamente...
si los niños van a la escuela y no aprenden,
eso devalúa la educación
y devalúa el gasto en educación,
de forma que gobiernos y partidos políticos puedan decir:
"Estamos gastando mucho dinero en educación,
pero los niños no aprenden.
No tienen las habilidades correctas.
Quizá deberíamos gastar menos".
Mejorar los sistemas educativos actuales para obtener resultados
es importante, pero no será suficiente.
¿Qué pasa en países que no tengan suficientes profesores cualificados?
Por ejemplo, Somalia.
Si cada estudiante somalí se hiciera maestro
-- si cada persona con estudios universitarios se hiciera maestro --
no tendríamos suficientes maestros.
¿Y qué hay de los niños que están en campos de refugiados,
o en zonas rurales muy remotas?
Tomemos a Filipe como ejemplo.
Filipe vive en una de las miles de comunidades
a la vera del río Amazonas.
Su pueblo de 78 personas tiene 20 familias.
Filipe y un compañero de estudios
eran los únicos dos en bachillerato en 2015.
Amazonas es un estado del noroeste brasileño.
Es cuatro veces y media más grande que Alemania,
y está completamente cubierto de jungla y ríos.
Hace una década, Filipe y su compañero
habrían tenido solo dos alternativas:
mudarse a Manaos, la capital, o dejar de estudiar por completo,
algo que la mayoría hizo.
En 2009, sin embargo, Brasil aprobó una nueva ley
que garantizó la educación secundaria para cada brasileño
y la obligación para cada estado de implementarla antes de 2016.
Pero dar acceso a una educación de alta calidad,
en el estado de Amazonas, es una tarea enorme y costosa.
¿Cómo conseguir profesores de matemáticas, ciencia e historia
en todas esas comunidades?
E incluso si los encuentras,
muchos de ellos no querrían mudarse allí.
Así que frente a esta tarea imposible,
funcionarios y representantes del estado
desarrollaron una increíble creatividad y espíritu emprendedor.
Desarrollaron la solución del centro de medios.
Funciona de esta manera.
Hay maestros de contenido especializado en Manaos
que dan clases de manera virtual
a más de mil aulas en esas comunidades dispersas.
Esas aulas tienen de 5 a 25 estudiantes,
y cuentan con el apoyo de un profesor de tutoría más generalista
para su aprendizaje y desarrollo.
Los 60 profesores de contenido en Manaos
trabajan con más de 2200 profesores de tutoría en esas comunidades
para personalizar sus clases al contexto y el tiempo.
Ahora, ¿por qué es importante
esta división entre maestro y maestro de tutoría?
Antes que nada, como dije, porque en muchos países,
simplemente no tenemos suficientes maestros cualificados.
Pero también porque los maestros hacen demasiadas cosas
para las que no fueron capacitados o se supone que no deberían hacer.
Miremos a Chile, por ejemplo.
En Chile, por cada médico,
hay cuatro personas y media,
cuatro personas y media de apoyo,
y Chile está en el extremo inferior del espectro aquí,
porque en los países en desarrollo, de media, cada médico
tiene 10 personas de apoyo.
Un profesor en Chile, sin embargo,
tiene menos de media persona,
0,3 personas, de apoyo.
Imaginen una sala de hospital con 20, 40, 70 pacientes
y un médico que hace todo por sí mismo:
sin enfermeros, sin ayudantes médicos,
nadie más.
Dirán que esto es absurdo e imposible,
pero es la realidad cotidiana de los maestros en el mundo
con aulas de 20, 40 o 70 estudiantes.
Entonces esta división entre maestros de contenidos y tutoría es increíble
porque está cambiando el paradigma del maestro,
para que cada uno haga lo que mejor puede hacer
para que los niños no solo estén en la escuela
sino en la escuela aprendiendo.
Y algunos de estos maestros de contenido,
se hicieron famosos.
Algunos se postularon para un cargo,
y ayudaron a mejorar el estatus de la profesión
para que más estudiantes quisieran ser maestros.
Y de este ejemplo me encanta
que va más allá de cambiar el paradigma del maestro.
Nos enseña a aprovechar la tecnología para el aprendizaje.
La transmisión en vivo es bidireccional,
es decir, Filipe y los otros pueden enviar información de regreso.
Y sabemos que la tecnología no siempre es perfecta.
Los funcionarios esperan
que entre el 5 y el 15 % de las aulas
estén sin conexión cada día
debido a inundaciones, antenas rotas o Internet que no funciona.
Y, sin embargo, Filipe es uno de más de 300 000 estudiantes
que se benefició del centro de medios
y tuvo acceso a la educación postprimaria.
Este es un ejemplo viviente
de que la tecnología no es solo un complemento
sino una pieza clave para el aprendizaje y puede acercar la escuela a los niños,
si no podemos acercar los niños a la escuela.
Ahora, los escucho.
Van a decir:
"¿Cómo vamos a implementar esto en todo el mundo?"
Yo misma he estado en el gobierno
y he visto lo difícil que es incluso implementar las mejores ideas.
Entonces, como comisión, comenzamos dos iniciativas
para hacer de la generación del aprendizaje una realidad.
La primera se llama Iniciativa de País Pionero.
Más de 20 países de África y Asia
se han comprometido a hacer de la educación su prioridad
y a transformar sus sistemas educativos para entregar resultados.
Hemos entrenado a líderes en cada país
en una metodología llamada enfoque a la entrega.
Esto persigue dos objetivos.
En la fase de planificación, llevamos a todos a una sala:
maestros, sindicatos de docentes, asociaciones de padres,
representantes del gobierno, ONGs, a todos...
para que la reforma y la solución que se nos ocurra
sean compartidas por todos y cuenten con el apoyo de todos.
Y la segunda fase,
es un tanto especial.
Es una especie de enfoque despiadado en el seguimiento.
Semana a semana, uno verifica
si se hizo lo que debía hacerse,
incluso a veces se envía a una persona físicamente al distrito o la escuela
para verificar que ocurrió en vez de esperar que suceda.
Puede que para muchos suene a sentido común,
pero no es una práctica común,
y por eso muchas reformas fallan.
Ha sido probado en Tanzania,
y allí la tasa de aprobados de los estudiantes de educación secundaria
se incrementó en un 50 % en poco más de dos años.
La próxima iniciativa para hacer de la generación del aprendizaje una realidad
es la financiación, quién pagará esto.
Creemos y argumentamos
que la financiación interna debe ser la columna vertebral de la inversión.
¿Recuerdan cuando antes les hablé sobre Vietnam
que superó a EE.UU. en PISA?
Eso se debe a un mejor sistema educativo,
pero también a que Vietnam ha aumentado su inversión
de un 7 a un 20 % de su presupuesto nacional en dos décadas.
Pero, ¿qué pasa si los países quieren pedir prestado dinero para educación?
Si uno pide un préstamo para construir un puente o una carretera,
es bastante fácil y directo,
pero no para la educación.
Es más fácil hacer una foto brillante de un puente y mostrarla a todos
que una foto de una mente educada.
Ese es un compromiso a más largo plazo.
Por eso se nos ocurrió una solución
para ayudar a los países a escapar de la trampa del ingreso medio,
países que ya no son lo suficientemente pobres o no son pobres, por suerte,
y por ende no pueden beneficiarse de becas o créditos a bajo interés,
y no son lo suficientemente ricos
para poder tener intereses atractivos en sus préstamos.
Así que reunimos dinero de donantes en un fondo financiero para la educación,
que proporcionará más financiación para la educación.
Subvencionaremos, o incluso eliminaremos por completo,
el pago de intereses sobre los préstamos
para que los países que se comprometan con las reformas
puedan pedir dinero prestado,
reformar su sistema educativo y pagar este dinero a lo largo del tiempo
mientras se benefician de una población mejor educada.
Esta solución ha sido reconocida en la última reunión del G20 en Alemania,
y finalmente hoy la educación está en la agenda internacional.
Pero permítanme llevar esto nuevamente al plano personal,
porque aquí es donde yace el impacto.
Sin esa decisión de invertir el presupuesto de un país joven,
20 % del presupuesto de un país joven en educación,
yo nunca podría haber ido a la escuela,
y mucho menos en 2014
convertirme en ministra en el gobierno
que terminó exitosamente la fase de transición.
El Premio Nobel de la Paz de Túnez en 2015
como la única democracia que surgió de la Primavera Árabe
es un legado de esa decisión audaz de liderazgo.
La educación es la lucha por los derechos civiles,
es la lucha por los derechos humanos de nuestra generación.
Educación de calidad para todos:
esa es la lucha por la libertad que tenemos que ganar.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)